hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
the story of blackberry epitomizes the
tech industry meteoric Rises and
catastrophic Falls
disruptive technology changes the market
landscape so quickly and drastically
that are both creates and swallows
billion-dollar companies blackberry went
from almost 20% of global mobile market
share to almost zero in a matter of a
few short years let's take a look at the
rise and fall of blackberry you are
walking ColdFusion TV
[Music]
to start the BlackBerry history we have
to go back to the 1980s in Canada
blackberry originated in Canada as the
company called research and motion or ha
a.m. for short in 1984
two engineering students Mike Lazaridis
and Douglas friggin start research in
motion early on the company worked on
wireless communications network
technology in 1996 research and motion
introduces the first two-way messaging
pager and by 1997 the company was
publicly traded on the Toronto Stock
Exchange one of the first products to
carry the BlackBerry name was another
pager with a full QWERTY keyboard which
later became synonymous with the brand
in fact the name BlackBerry comes from
the shape and feel of the keys on their
keyboard this pagers main strength was
the devices integration with emails
this gave business users an executive
sales reps the first easy-to-use
on-the-go access to email and this was a
huge deal and in here
blackberry would find its market the
next model would integrate telephone
capabilities something that hadn't ever
really been done well before at the time
in the 1990s does a race to dominate the
newly developed handheld space palm
Ericsson and IBM were all in on the game
even Apple tried with the Apple Newton
and a stylus the latter ended up being a
disaster because the software wasn't up
to scratch BlackBerry looked at this
market from a very different point of
view they were going to innovate what
none of the big players in the 1990s
realized was that bandwidth was very
limited for data transmissions Mike the
founder of Research In Motion did
understand this limitation within the
BlackBerry devices he had created an
instrument that distributed the bits of
data communications in such a way that
it wouldn't overload the networks
so while others were charging massive
amounts of money for something that
barely worked over a network BlackBerry
devices just worked this combined with a
keyboard that could be effectively used
with sums made blackberry have the clear
advantage another
part of BlackBerry's success was their
guerilla marketing blackberry employees
would often go to conferences and
spotted business people who are using
chunky laptops the BlackBerry employees
would give these people a blackberry to
try for free for a month as the business
users replaced their laptops of
blackberries this created massive
word-of-mouth marketing and soon the
devices became a necessity and took over
the business world the device was just
so much more practical than other phones
at the time the hype of the BlackBerry
soon carried through down to
non-business users and BlackBerry
decided to target them to integrating
more features for the everyday user the
BlackBerry Pearl was their step into
this new space it featured multimedia
elements such as a camera and came with
a new service called blackberry
messenger in the mid-2000s service
providers typically charge per text
message the most common form of
messaging back then but blackberry
messenger used Internet data to transfer
cheap and quick messages much like
iMessage and iPhones today back then it
was nothing short of revolutionary it
allowed people to escape their text
message limited plans this innovation
made blackberry very popular and soon
enough blackberry was everywhere at its
peak the company had 20% share of global
smartphone market and 50% of the United
States market it was a Goliath in the
tech world its users ranged young and
old professional and casual the
company's position in the market was so
strong so how did it go all so wrong
it was the year 2007 George W Bush was
president the first Transformers movie
was released and Windows Vista was still
fresh Steve Jobs went on the stage at
Macworld to talk about a new product
Apple was working on it was a phone a
mini computer a web browser and an email
machine all in the one device meanwhile
in Canada founder of blackberry Mike
Lazaridis looked at the announcement
that Steve Jobs had just made and said
quote this is an impossibility with the
networks wouldn't be able to carry this
it's illogical that anyone would even
propose this end quote the thing was
Mike was right the iPhone drop cause and
Apple face lawsuits for a product that
simply just didn't work properly but
then after the initial setbacks the
iPhone began to work and Mike became
very wrong within that two year period
the iPhone had taken the world by storm
it's interactive the multi-touch
capacitive touchscreen captured the
imagination of users and developers by
the time blackberry realized what a
serious threat that this was they were
already followers it said to the problem
Android phones like HTC also started to
hit the market pushing the barriers and
increasing competition this was new for
blackberry as previously they didn't
have many strong competitors there was
Sony Ericsson Nokia and Motorola to you
but blackberry was set above as a
premium mobile phone brand almost
overnight that all changed the iPhone
did many things better than Blackberry a
bigger screen very interaction by
capacitive touch but a multimedia
playback and a bit of camera which is
some but it was the browser that really
differentiated the two blackberry had a
much smaller screen to render images
limiting the way that the layout could
be displayed would nearly double the
screen size the iPhones showed its
competitor out of the water allowing
more ways to interact with the page not
only this but most interactions with the
device just simply felt more natural too
but blackberry wouldn't go down
a fight contrary to popular belief at
this time blackberry was still doing
well they're expanding in Indonesia
India and other parts of the world they
were a huge company and even had to
build new factories to keep up with
demand
once the iPhone got its original Network
problem solved blackberry reacted the
next phone would have a much larger
screen while still paying homage to the
QWERTY keyboard that made them famous
this time utilizing a slide down tab the
issue at the core of blackberry was that
it was trying to compete in a dynamic
market by changing its physical features
all the while its operating system
remained relatively unchanged blackberry
soon realized this and reacted by
changing their Java based OS with a new
OS built in a language called Qi and X
but unfortunately developers simply
didn't like Q and X they opted to make
apps for Android and Apple instead
because they could have exposure to much
more of the market ultimately it was a
destructive feedback loop for blackberry
less third-party apps meant fewer people
wanting to buy BlackBerry devices
meaning developers had fewer people to
sell their apps to T which in turn meant
that developers would produce fewer apps
for blackberry and the destructive loop
continues in the space of a year
blackberry had dropped from the most
popular mobile brand to third in another
attempt to save blackberry they changed
the operating system yet again but now
they jump ship to their competitors by
using Android OS but unfortunately this
move demonstrated that blackberry was no
longer different from any other Android
phone and held no edge in this newly
developing market so naturally they
pivoted to becoming a software company
these days the company mainly focuses on
security and enterprise software they
still do cell phones but they only
account for 0.05 percent of the global
market effectively nothing
Android and the iPhone undoubtedly
killed blackberry but it was black
burying themselves who allowed them to
do this they were at the top and
complacency crept in the models of
blackberry didn't really show any great
leaps forward or exciting new technology
to make you trade in your old one
they simply kept producing the same
phone model over and over again the
cameras did improve a little and they
did have new improved features here and
there but not the big leaps that was
seen with Apple and Android devices at
the time
blackberry stopped competing stat on its
hands and once competitors got ahead
they woke up and started playing
catch-up to add to this their executives
didn't have vision they pushed the
company into what they thought consumers
wanted instead of actually listening to
them jim balsillie
former co co blackberry in 2010 was
quoted as saying there may be 300,000
apps to the iPhone but the only app you
need is your browser this perhaps
epitomizes the hard-headed culture and
lack of vision in the company which
would ultimately lead to us destruction
the company leadership failed in several
aspects firstly they fail to realize
that non-business consumers would
eventually drive the market secondly
they reacted poorly to the new app
economy which meant the iPhone and
Android devices so popular and lastly
they didn't foresee that mobile devices
will evolve from a simple communication
service to full mobile entertainment
devices the executives persisted with a
QWERTY keyboard in the face of
touchscreen devices just another example
of failing to see where the market was
heading this wasn't the easiest thing to
see by any means but in the early stages
of Android when they saw the iPhone they
immediately realized that touch was the
future and pivoted their designs to get
rid of their keyboards blackberry could
have done this what I do give Jim and
Mike credit for is the way they ran that
company there was enough gas left in the
tank if you will to keep the company
going and by that I mean Mike Lazaridis
still had a library of innovations while
Jim Balsillie and his financing the
company had over 5 billion dollars of
cash when it ran into trouble in 2000
it was had no debt it was conservatively
financed it allowed them to buy time to
get through their problems the story of
blackberry once again highlights the
speed at which the technology market can
move blackberry got on top by providing
a great product but somewhere along the
line they stopped innovating when the
iPhone came out they were complacent and
didn't realize the future until it was
too late even as far as 2010 they didn't
believe in the concept of apps
ultimately blackberry was a company
which rose to the top but didn't know
how to stay there they weren't hungry to
consistently make a better product Apple
and Google Android's fierce competition
over the years continues to push the
boundaries of mobile phone technology
blackberry just never felt this pressure
until it was too late and in the tech
world when you start playing catch-up
you've already lost
blackberry still makes phones today but
they could have been their apple of
today if they reacted faster to the
iPhone it definitely wouldn't have been
easy but it was definitely possible as a
result the company couldn't keep a share
of the market and in total that is the
rise and fall of blackberry so thanks
for watching this video
it's a doozy ever in a blackberry and if
you did would you like to still see
blackberry dominate the smartphone
market let me know in the comments
section below if you want to see more
videos on science technology business
and history you can subscribe to this
channel I'm sure you'll find something
interesting here don't forget to check
out the podcast versions of these videos
as well I'll leave that in link below
thanks for watching this has been - go
go and you've been watching cold fusion
and I'll catch you again soon for the
next video
cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion the clear-thinking
[Music]